on the first hour of his first day party
black how am I the first person like
season 16 of The Voice returns this
Monday with new judge John Legend and
apparently the other coaches don't plan
on making it easy for him but oh don't
worry cuz John has a few advantages that
the other coaches don't John will you
bring your awards in just to let
everybody know that you have any guy and
you're gonna have to throw that out
there right there you got to go with it
no you know why because I'm positive
that John will fall into the category of
horrible pile of doodoo coach what
advice you have for John I don't have
any I don't wanna help him at all
because I've worked with John in this
capacity before and I know he's got mad
skills because and so I'm worried so all
the coaches are ganging up on John but
don't worry he has a secret weapon and
I'm not just talking about his cute
mini-me nine-month-old miles is there
any concern that he can use Chrissy and
her online presence it's a weapon she
trolls me more than she knows anybody
else yeah John may be the new guy but
Blake wants to settle the score with
Kelly last season Kelly goes out gets a
country artist and she wins will you
ever let that happen again
you went right for the throat there did
you want to see me cry is that your goal
as an interviewer and honest you cry
hashtag make Blake cry you ever seen
that movie a 40 year old virgin where
they ripped the wax off Steve Carell's
chest that's because she's associated
with misery
[Applause]
[Music]